I don't know what you're doing right now
I know what I'm doing I'm sat doing
deals making phone calls booking
viewings making money I'm with my man
honor hey guys
on on Bonaire in fact I'm almost about
to call an agent I'll give you an idea
of the kind of things we say when we
call agent so listen closely okay so
what how did you come across this
property first of all we found it on
Rightmove yes we determined a location
an area we were excited about we put in
our numbers based on on obviously your
criteria following the formula the step
by step template founders property looks
good it's got a tenant that's sitting
there already so it's good to go let's
make a call let's see what the agent has
to say now we got a see didn't have in
the making I'm putting in the making
okay here we go
let's call them so is this cool hi good
morning Who am I speaking to
very good morning to you my name is our
nonbonus
I'm currently on Rightmove and I believe
you have a property for sale it's a
three-bedroom terraced house on the road
hemsworth yeah I believe and I
understand that there's a tenant in
there and I just wanted to understand
something it says here that the tenant
is paying 568 pounds a month okay
now I looked at the property and I've
done a little bit of calculations
obviously because numbers are important
yes
and I can see first of all the
property's been on sale since September
so it's been on the market for quite
some time okay so I guess the reason why
I'm calling is because I'm doing some
mathematics I'm doing some calculations
based on the asking price based on the
rental income I'm trying to see as an
investor how I can make this work and
make the numbers work for me and I can
see that the hosting price is in the
region of 90,000 now what I don't want
to do is I don't want to book an
appointment come up there you know I
don't want to waste anybody's time
obviously I value your time as I've only
mine that's why I said I'd make a quick
call do you feel and I don't want to I
don't want to come across cheeky or rude
do you feel that the owners would be
comfortable accepting an offer in the
low 80s
okay okay and so what do you think they
would be comfortable mid-80s again I'm
just trying to make the numbers work
yeah and again I don't want to waste
anybody's time and I'm very respectful
for the owners and yourself I just don't
want to waste anybody's time so what do
you think there would be more like okay
good okay and thank you so much for your
time I'm very grateful I appreciate it
I'll do some calculations yeah and if I
want to pursue it you'll hear from me
soon thank you very much and have a
happy New York now what most people
would do is they'd go and look around
the house and then put forward an offer
of 81 or ever just to piss off the agent
be told no and then their waste did they
trip up them all the time what I
understood was he had a too many
conversation yeah and and you reject it
yeah and always be polite that's so
important yeah but you were rejected but
are you any poorer
no I'm closer to my yes exactly so
that's the thing you need to just number
one be prepared to be told no if you're
not embarrassed about the low
of the offer then it's probably too high
and also don't waste time viewing houses
that you don't know whether it's going
to be a good deal and I first find out
if it's gonna be a good deal up front by
asking just the way I'm on did so great
jobs you do some more goals
definitely